Stargate is 28 years old yesterday
slightly belated birthday gift here but
I just want to talk about a movie that
genuinely blew my mind when it was
released back in 1994. welcome to
Sidetrack your Sci-Fi TV and Movie
Channel on holiday
[Music]
so here I am actually I'm up at my
Caravan for the weekend enjoying the
lovely British weather doesn't it rain
in yep but yesterday was the birthday
the 28th anniversary of when the
original Stargate movie starring James
Spader and Kurt Russell came out
oh sorry
hey hey don't
two figures on either side
praying beside a pyramid with the sun
directly above it
he's right
I was in front of us the whole time
now this is a film written by Roland
Emrick and Dean Devlin it had a stop
stop beginning but then spawned three of
the greatest TV shows ever made it's
under the cover Stones yes
my father founded 1928 made out of a
mineral unlike any found on Earth and
probably my favorite sci-fi franchise
and that's coming from a Bonafide
Trekkie so that's saying a lot
[Music]
but a little bit about the movie
it nearly didn't happen it was actually
produced by Canal plus a big French
production company and they didn't have
any distribution rights so Dean Devlin
and Roland Emerick had to wandered
around and get somebody to buy it that's
somebody turned out to be MGM who only
actually paid 15 million dollars for the
movie didn't think it was going to do
very well had no interest in actually
investing any real money in it it then
went on to be their 10th highest
grossing movie of all time coming from
one of the big five Studios that's
pretty impressive
and took nearly 200 million dollars in
the box office
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
actually when it was released in October
1994 was the highest grossing movie fall
release ever at that point
it held that record for about four years
I believe until answer is released
um
in
uh 998.
if this film had been released today
though I would have gone and excitedly
watched it in no small part because the
critics before the release hated it
Rotten Tomatoes rated this at 51 thanks
to the critics reviews they thought it
was too flashy too many special effects
that their writing wasn't very good and
all of that sort of thing what the
critics normally say about this type of
popcorn movie
that to me would have been underlining
that I desperately want to see this
movie not just because I love James
Spader and not just because Kurt Russell
this was really his big comeback
but because the critics hated it is
always good
generally speaking when a critics love a
movie
I don't
know we've left 45 seconds he's leaving
turn it off I'm trying to I can't disarm
it what
I can't stop it they got it rigged
so
the film didn't have the best start
another interesting fact about this
movie actually is that um Roland Emerick
and Dean Devlin wrote the film together
but actually they had two completely
different stories one about an alien in
the desert and another one about this
Transportation device a gate-like thing
two completely different stories that
they merged together to form Stargate so
again this was never one original story
it was actually Dean Devlin and Roland
Emerick just like I imagine them just
like chatting over a pint one day going
I've got this idea I can't quite figure
it out I've got this idea I can't quite
figure it out and they Portland together
and created just amazing Stargate I can
imagine like a light going off and like
ding as they realized what they had
[Music]
I've got an idea
they actually really struggled to even
get the movie released through MGM as
well and Dean Devlin talked back in 19
sorry 2008 about how he used to wander
around sci-fi conventions that's what
we're trying to drum up interest to try
and get the thing made
so it just amazes me that this was a
movie that nearly didn't happen
but
I would love to know in the comments
really quickly when did you first come
across the Stargate movie what what sort
of impact did the film have on you when
it first came out please guys get in the
comments and tell us also I'd love to
know you know they never did get to make
a sequel with James spade and Kurt
Russell do you think that's a shame or
do you think the TV shows were better
off with it just being a one-hit movie
I'd love to know again what you think if
you are new to the Channel please like
subscribe hit that Bell notification it
really helps us out and if you are
enjoyed the content and you want to help
me pay for my little holidays and
weekends away you can become a fully
fledged stock tracker and hit that join
Button as always guys please stay safe
and um I'm hoping the weather's a little
bit nicer Where You Are see you soon
[Music]